la russie annonce la fin des manoeuvres
d'entraînement militaire qui ont débuté
il y à un mois dans le sud du pays et
parfois près de la frontière ukrainienne
d exercice qui avait notamment provoqué
de vives tensions entre les deux pays on
en parle avec notre correspondante à
moscou vera goffman
verra bonjour dites nous que sait-on au
sujet de la fin de ses entraînements
bonjour nadège à dix mille militaires
russes rentrer dans leurs bases après
des exercices qui ont duré un mois les
entraînements se sont déroulés dans le
sud de la russie qu on vous l'avait dit
au sein de la région d'astrakhan
volgograd rostov krasnodar ainsi que
dans les républiques du caucase du nord
est en crimée certaines de ces régions
fictivement se trouve à la frontière
russo ukrainienne source de tensions ces
dernières semaines entre la russie et
plusieurs pays occidentaux
ces derniers accusant moscou de préparer
une attaque contre l'ukraine les
militaires russes quant à eux affirment
que malgré la fin des exercices et
restent vigilants quant à d'éventuelles
situations d'urgence je vous propose
d'écouter
afin de maintenir un haut niveau de
préparation au combat dans toutes les
formations et unité du district
militaire sud des unités de service des
renforts et des forces pour faire face
aux conséquences d'éventuelles d'urgence
seront déployés pendant la période des
vacances du nouvel an de plus les unités
de défense aérienne les équipages de
certains navires de la flotte de la mer
noire et de la flottille caspienne des
unités de guerre électronique et les
équipes de service des véhicules aériens
tactiques de l'armée et sans pilotes
seront déployés pendant les dix premiers
jours de janvier s'ils souhaitent
néanmoins obtenir dès que possible une
réponse des états unis et de le temps à
propos de leurs demandes de garanties de
sécurité mutuelle mais il n'y a pas de
date limite a déclaré ce matin le porte
parole du kremlin dmitri peskov la
diplomatie russe a initié ces derniers
jours ce projet qui pourrait déboucher
sur un dialogue avec washington
prochainement moscou a présenté le 12
décembre des propositions et à 2 monde
et l'engagement des états unis pour
bloquer le déploiement de l'otan vers
l'est notamment dans des pays comme
l'ukraine parmi les autres demandes du
kremlin obtenir la certitude que
l'alliance atlantique ne construisent
pas à l'avenir des bases militaires dans
des états de l'ex-bloc soviétique
verhaeghe hoffman correspondante pour rt
france à moscou merci pour ces
précisions